did the Pope give his Blessing to
same-sex relationships yesterday as the
media breathlessly reported no not quite
but I understand why you might think so
in a new document for the dicastri for
the doctrine of Faith formerly known as
the holy office formerly known as the
Inquisition the church has declared that
priests can give same-sex couples a
quote spontaneous blessing but not a
blessing that is quote lurgical or
resembles marriage no quote clothes
gestures or words that are proper to a
wedding can be included so as to quote
avoid any form of confusion or Scandal
the blessings cannot be connected in any
way to civil unions and quote rights and
prayers that could create confusion
between what constitutes a marriage
which is the exclusive stable and
indisoluble Union between a man and a
woman naturally open to the generation
of children so no the church did not
approve the blessing of same-sex unions
exactly